and at 1:48 there was a shot of Benicio
del Toro hmm and he's playing a
character big named DJ yeah DJ well
which is one of the most hard for now
Star Wars name should ever come across
it's actually just I think it's D in the
gerbil silent yeah hey it's like it's
responsive like a gasps yeah
hey guys Greg Alva here and it's John
here so we just watch the reaction for
Star Wars last Jedi behind the scenes or
at least at d23 expo this video is
really awesome like we mentioned in our
reaction there's reasons why we're more
excited for this than the force awakens
primarily I think it does primarily come
down to the fact Rian Johnson is doing
it Rian Johnson has been pretty
consistent with his work into sci-fi
arena what I like what they've been
doing with Star Wars is the beginning
directors who are experienced with
territory on this scale like I feel like
a lot of times with big studio films
they get these directors who come from
much smaller films to do these big
studio films and sometimes that the best
choice they could have made and
sometimes they shouldn't have done that
yeah but Rian Johnson seemed like a
perfect fit welcome Rian Johnson's had I
feel like the perfect upward climb Yami
started with at least I found him when
he did brick and that's sort of a Nyonya
are very down very uh down to earth and
scale and then you know there's stuff
like Wooper but even like Breaking Bad
like breaking bad got him into the
Academy the looper was also this like is
one of the darker sci-fi films that was
not epic in terms of how massive the
scale was but epic intone world of
storytelling it had that sort of like
near-future quality were like yeah
there's future technology but things are
still kind of [ __ ] around here yeah
it's like future technology but things
are still kind of run down yeah as the
case with any sequels a lot of people
have been reporting back that this one's
going to be darker than the force
awakened kind of I don't and I give the
word of mouth from like certain cast
members gets kind of confusing and this
is supposed to be like a fire strike
stuff and the way how about a lot darker
or not I'm not sure but I feel like to
take it in a darker direction in a more
cinematic emotional direction I feel
like Rian Johnson is a great choice for
it and I appreciate that in this video a
lot of people get raving about how it's
Rian Johnson's vision for Star Wars yeah
because yeah I didn't really feel that
out when people talked about JJ for the
force awakens yeah there's more about
Star Wars coming back they probably have
to be a lot more discreet about every
we're revealing or saying that here
everyone's really raving about guys Ryan
Johnson's vision for this is going to be
pretty fantastic you know yeah yeah and
I mean it's just as a fan of his that
gives me a lot of hope and it's like we
said in the last video of the thing that
I think Daisy Ridley said about it being
unexpected but right sounds like the
perfect things and everyone a lot of
people so different variations of that
as well yeah also one thing I appreciate
about how they have it handled footage
of Terry Fisher in here as I feel like
they have to be very delicate with using
Carrie Fisher footage and the reason why
is because yes she passed away it was a
very heartbreaking time for many people
and the reason I say the word delicate
is because you don't want to like put
too much over in the point where it
seems like they're taking it where you
might get the misconception that they're
taking advantage of the fact that she
died it's yeah it doesn't feel
exploitive yeah that's the word I'm
looking for yeah I feel like they used
her just enough because like you do have
to I mean you know she a part of the
heart and you don't use her at all then
it feels insulting yeah you have to user
at the just the right time I mean this
is just a you know like a BTS clip but
it seems like everything is kinda on
that level it just gives you a good
sense for everything that's what I
walked away with it's like you get a
sense for every part of the production
and so you're like oh cool really great
looking practical said and practical
ships and stuff here and there and then
here's some puppet and here's what the
CGI people are doing and here's Macey
Lupita Nyong'o in in a mocap gear yeah
you know you really get a sense for the
scope and size of the production and you
know for especially for a flagship movie
like this I feel like that's pretty cool
that shot that they had around the 21
second mark with like this looks like
some type of rock is exploding some type
of hold of all I remember seeing there
is a shot in the trailer where there is
debris that looks like that yeah that
red debris I'm really curious like where
the racket it looks violet like there's
something kind of violent about that
yeah Midori and I'm wondering what that
really links to is very striking for
sure and any time bright red things even
that cameraman getting drenched in the
headshot yeah
the camera wrapped up yeah a film camera
that looks like an actual film camera I
feel like a ragdoll those are kinda
choose to shoot on film that would be a
smart choice into the originals were
shot on film if you want to you know
really drive home the whole we're
attached to the original yeah yeah like
that's a good idea
as far as a continuation off of what
they were doing with force awakens as I
know JJ was very specific about keeping
it as much practical as he possibly
could it seems like from looking at the
sets it feel like they're doing the
exact same thing here maybe even more so
I hope so I mean I feel like that is
part of the DNA of Star Wars and Disney
is smart enough to know that yeah we
really got to go all out and put this
stuff on screen because that's part of
what you latch on to someone and I'm
thinking that the actors chemistry will
probably even be stronger in this one
it's kind of like a show yeah you know
in a show when you have like it's the
first time these actors are working
together so after a few episodes then
they finally in other chemistry becomes
a lot more natural the rapport becomes
better yeah and there's so much footage
of behind the scenes of these guys is
really laughing really bonding all them
doing it them I'm thinking that the the
camaraderie here in the chemistry not
scream I play even better and more
natural not that it was a problem in the
last one but you know in terms of like
specific dynamics so really cause us to
really latch on to relationship so I
felt like we really latched on to like
individual characters yeah and I feel
like in this one will probably latch on
more to the relationship dynamics these
guys all have well you know they're
under way on this again I got imagine
least some of the crew and the cast
especially are kind of like a family now
yeah you know cuz we're doing a lot of
this together yeah we gotta do after
this we're taking yeah but you get some
shots of actors you don't see in the
force awakens at 1:13 there's a shot of
laura dern who i saw her in the HBO
miniseries big love okay i'm a big love
a little lies yeah yeah she was
fantastic in that too and it's like the
other three actresses in that show are
the ones who're the main stars but she's
also really good in that show so cool to
see her like back in the morning I
remind first movie with her with
Jurassic Park again I'm a blockbuster
head so I think it's really cool for her
to be in this I like her outfit she
plays a character her hairdo
vice-admiral
Hamelin hold oh I don't know that the
character from Star Wars before and like
of the carbons or something yeah hard
words the new parts of its universe Amy
but I'm excited to see if she's a
touched upon character here or she's
just like hey cool cameo from Laura Dern
you know cuz sometimes it happens at
Bella yeah I hope she's got a sheet in
here some yeah yeah they have phasma in
here at one point it showed that she's
being more involved in the film okay
some people weren't the impression that
she died in the first one no and I
wasn't under that impression I thought
they just like ah let's get rid of her
but I didn't think they killed her
oh no yeah for whatever reason I walked
out of the force awakens being like oh
yeah they just sent that character but
she's going to come back later you know
yeah any much like the thing I was
excited about will probably happen in a
future Star Wars yeah because I was
excited about you know her casting and
some of the other special new people and
some of them didn't get tons to do in
force awakens somehow was and she's
considered one of the best characters on
Game of Thrones and yeah Jack to see her
in this and now damaged is barely in
force awakens and rather it's really
pushed to the side yeah I'm hoping Rian
Johnson and the whole Star Wars team
took big notice of the fan backlash on
that yeah and decides we're gonna really
find at least a couple of scenes to
maker of strong use and especially have
a freaking point yeah she kicks ass in
game is oh yeah I just be cemented in a
show full of not likable characters you
the one of the gathers I really like
she's managed to keep major but toxin
that yeah right now she's just like a
cooler looking stormtrooper and they
don't tease in the in this
behind-the-scenes of her doing a crazy
action sequence but I'm hoping we get to
see that or some kind of crazy
leadership side to her she's going to
whip all the stormtroopers into shape
and see some mass shoot straight he's
gonna kill all the stormtroopers and
inherit all their energy and power
become this giant mega surrender mega
true yesterday you know her ago that
yeah yeah I got one forty eight there
was a shot of Benicio del Toro hmm and
he's playing a character big-name DJ for
a second there I thought that was Andy
Serkis well any circus isn't this he is
that's why I got close like I'll just
take it outside that I and then
you pointed out and I realized I was
mistaken he's a general stoked jump and
jump to take over the gas don't get on
to some of these nefarious feeds is
really all about it I love changing
times nobody knows who I am it's great
one day Andy Serkis will plate non mocap
characters I feel like every movie he's
in should be like King Kong where he's a
mocap character and then on screen
Chaeronea then he really will be the
most hard working on acknowledged night
I don't think people really have much
information on who the DJ character
supposed to be no but I think we need to
little Toro is a fantastic actor in love
days and Guardians the MCU and now he's
in Star Wars as well this Disney buddy
looks more like a regular guy in this
one maybe hey maybe he's from an
earth-like planet yeah plays a detective
cool maybe they abducted his character
from Zaccone
there's also a shot I like 2:29 John
boyega and Daisy really are dancing I
hope that's not them goofing off behind
the scenes yeah and that that's a real I
hope that's like people being shot yeah
yeah I wouldn't smash the black and says
one year earlier miss training was my
husband and this becomes like a credit
sequence were like the credits roll to
the left and all the cast is dancing to
the same but on different sets yeah cuz
that's really my favorite way to end
everything you know how Disney does he's
like Star Wars shows like Darth Vader
comes out dancing is that yeah I hope
they should start doing that it's about
time they brought the Christmas special
you know heavier into the actual
mythology yeah I feel like what about my
mom man you know how much people talk
about in reference the Star Wars
Christmas special I mean had it seems
weird that at this point they just
wouldn't remake it for the Monterey
arguably up there with Empire Strikes
Back definitely is that line that they
end on with Carrie Fisher you know
seeing how it's about family well part
of me goes over the news with us
computers that is harboring it here you
feel it you feel it and and for anyone
who's like seeing documentaries or
interviews you're like that's that's
pretty much who Carrie Fisher is and
I've met a couple people who've met her
just on the street not only action but
bumped one person hit ran into her in
the hit her car they had to exchange
info at the end like they talked for a
while she got a photo like she's such a
nice person and and you know a lot of
ways Star Wars is about family plot
Skywalker's you know yeah and also just
you know I like she's been with this
series since the start and so his Mark
Hamill and a lot of people you know like
I do there is a certain family vibe I
get you know even just isolated from
this but also just across Star Wars and
I wonder how they're going to handle you
know the fact that she passed away yeah
are they going to have an off screen I
think I really hope I'm wondering are
they going to do some with clearance
weirdly I feel like as much flack as
Furious 7 got for how they handled for
the Paul Walker CGI face I feel like the
majority thought it was Jerry and
effective yeah it was effective it
didn't feel insulting but surprisingly
it just looked a little silly when you
could tell it CGI well I think it helps
knowing that his brother you know sir
I'm to do right and you know it's
everybody kind understands like we we
have to get this done however we got to
do this for study actually and I know
they did finish filming I think they had
some post to complete after she passed
away but I know they finished filming
all her scenes but I'm wondering like
how are they gonna are they going to
handle it in a certain way after the
last Jedi in the next installment are
they going to say something about how
she did passed away are they going to
give her some type of goodbye scene are
they going to give her some type of
death scene like what are they gonna do
with that they're going to do some you
know the face cgi thing that people do
which people found insulting enough as
it was 401
there was definitely especially the
debate over Peter Cushing at the time
yeah but then they even had persuasion
show up at the end that people thought
was really weird
just like yeah it definitely looked
weird I mean like it was before it was
ghoulish yeah you know and now it's I
don't know how it would feel about that
now weird scene from rogue one that they
can do it and at the time you know that
was just it was just creepy looking I
definitely wouldn't have wouldn't want
to see them just keep using that
character I feel like that character has
Tex
oh yeah I would easily have to exit
if they need to use it for that purpose
I understand as long as the way that
they handle you know as long as the
context and then the way they justified
in the story makes sense yeah I don't
like as long as disrespectful that way
we have the technology I guess so and
you know I can't imagine anybody
invested in these films or so long would
be like no I don't want it to make sense
well guys tell me are you excited for
Star Wars the last Jedi do you want to
see this do I think it's do I feel like
a lot different then are you a Star Wars
fan anymore does anybody likes already
like it I feel like it makes like no
money I know I have never hear about it
I I feel like it's like one of the least
talked about things on the Internet
barely any merchandise like I've tried
about Star Wars
he should the other guys I couldn't find
anything Disneyland doesn't seem to care
about it either no they're not going to
employ like they're going to knock down
half the park and build Star Wars happen
or anything like that subscribe to the
real rejects click that notification
bell - out Humphrey on Twitter and some
on it social media manager of Blum house
and as always you can go check out our
patreon comm slash the real rejects or
exclusive perks and rewards that all go
to contributing to keeping this channel
running much love to all of you